тому назад четверо задню кішка купа
речей всі мішечники барахольчики
евакуації солідара
Здрасті Мене звуть Гнат і я займаюсь
евакуаціями цивільних людей на
Донбасі
вибачте
Алло
ти бачив я надіслав там на світі Будуть Два
людини, а не одна
а все добре
хто ви за національністю
але ви говорите російською, бо в
вас російське коріння Так у мене мама
Росіянка Чому
Тому що почалася війна і я хотів
допомагати тут тоді До речі я був у
Москві останній півтора року вже в
Москві було багато випадків Москві коли
якщо у мене не було британського паспорта
мене було утримували але завдяки йому
мене відпускали там на протестах і так
далі У мене брат уже давно живе у
Україні та до початку війни
Я був впевнений, що буде Війна більше ніж
на сто відсотків по всій інформації Я
намагався виїхати, а потім коли почалася
війна наступного дня ми відразу ж
прийняли рішення приїхати сюди разом із
моєю мамою
люди
евакуація
так давайте не речей А діти вийшов
настільки не відвеземо
останні Ось напевно три-чотири місяці
вже з травня з 9 травня напевно
вже цілеспрямованіше ними займаюся
евакуаціями та гуманітарної допомоги
евакуації тривають солідар ми
виїжджаємо
коли ми тільки починали робити
евакуації солідара було там 50-60
людина день зараз звичайно Це набагато
менше тому, що ми вже вивезли більше
тисячі людей я думаю що якщо удар
виїхала ми доводимо їх до однієї церкви у
Краматорську де вони можуть переночувати
вони там заряджають телефони вирішують свої
маршрути далі людей які живуть у
таких будинках все одно доводиться
вмовляти виїжджати
відмовилися зараз вже той момент, коли
просто люди не хочуть нікуди їхати
люди
мені 95 років я вже ніби можна вже
поїхали багато людей не хочуть виїжджати
тому що
тут
Ти ж знаєш
Ти знаєш А там фіг його знає як буде
деякі люди взагалі повертаються у них
не вийшло у нас є одна сім'я Вона
живе у бахмунському там із усього солідара
найгірша ситуація усі будинки
знищені майже під основу виходити
з будинку вкрай небезпечно весь час обстріли
і там є мама з дівчинкою з якими я
спілкувався минулого тижня І ось вони
виїхали
зняли житло потім вони закінчилися гроші
вони повернулися назад туди вони повернулися
вже в такий випадок і таких людей
говорити виїхати вже буде дуже складно
тому що вони спробували вони поїхали
самі Та вони поїхали не через якийсь
фонд вони стали самі шукати не вдалося
Тепер вони вважають, що ніхто не допоможе
складно бачити і постійно стикатися з
людьми, які поставили крісло своєю
життя Ось це складно які коли люди
себе в пряме кажуть що
нехай Ми тут уже помремо
це складно
Доброго дня Ми за вами це ваш дім та а
документи ви взяли свої
є люди які говорять так я хотів би
жити в Україні, але в принципі я хочу
просто жити вся в будинку і все ось я хочу
жити в солідарі Це моє місто Я хочу
бути тут переважна більшість Мені
здається на даний момент вже просто все
і просто
Я не думаю, що ми тут можемо судити
людей за те, що вони там якісь
недостатньо патріотично налаштовані
тому що ви спробуєте побудете в
таких умовах ось Київ скільки там
місяць-два Побув І скільки людей поїхало і
все-таки це дуже сильно розхитує
психіку тому я думаю мені здається
потрібно з розумінням ставитися з великим
нам усім намагатися ставитися з великим
розумінням до людей які живуть у таких
умовах
[музика]
нам зателефонували
сказали, що є поранений
Ми приїхали і в нього була майже відірвана
рука між ними ушкодження Ноги тобто
я подивився Спочатку я хотів вкласти на
турніку потім я так прикинув що там уже
немає турнікету
потім я так подивився в нього витікало
вже
частина мозку що там були дуже
серйозні травми
[музика]
ми як би його вивезли там як сказати
відносність
зробили що ми могли забезпечили там
дихання
у лікарню мали оперувати він
помер
[музика]
Я не маю почуття провини що хтось гине
тому що вони гинуть не через мене
іноді я думаю міг би я зробити на них
більше може бути іноді міг би раз не
зробив те напевно не міг
чим я винен те, що їх убив снаряд
швидше за все їх направив російське
артилерія Ні я не відчуваю абсолютно
це винним
але тобі теж позитивних емоцій теж
багато дає знаєте коли когось
вивозиш що вони безпеки
спочатку не сильно так було, а потім
перед моїми очима він померла тітка потім
я дуже сильно
бомбою розірвала І потім я панікувала я
не хотіла жити якось грошей нема і
страшно їхати нікого не знаєш нічого
нікуди нікуди ми їхали Ну є на світі
добрі люди добрі які допомагають
їде машина ми підходимо до цієї машини
і потім тут Гнат і він мені подарував
черепашку
Чому ми робимо, бо можемо і все
Я отримую почуття що я роблю
правильно і потрібно роблю Це важливо
можливо не всім але мені особисто це
важливо Я відчуваю що я не дарма живу свою
життя це дуже багато тобі віддає і не
замислюєшся про якісь не знаю
умовностях
такі кросівки одягнути кофту чи там
Піти праворуч піти ліворуч просто
зроблено те, що правильно ти займаєшся
і все тому це теж спрощує мені мою
життя